(soft techno music)
- [Hannu] Darkness is the canvas
and the light is my brush.
With light painting,
you can create new
world sense of darkness.
My name is Hannu Huhtamo,
and I paint with light.
I live in Finland.
We have amazing nature here.
We have long summer nights
that are warm and full of light,
but on the opposite, there
is also this dark part.
It's called polar night.
It starts in December, and
it lasts for about 50 days.
The sun doesn't rise
above the horizon at all.
And, for a light painter,
that is quite good.
I do long exposure photography,
which is a photographic technique
that allows me to draw with light.
The exposure times can
vary from seconds to hours,
and the idea is to use the light sources
as brushes or pencils
and the dark surroundings are the canvas.
When I start, I might do
some sketches on paper.
After that, I go to the location,
I search for details
that I want to emphasize.
It's sunlight treatment,
it will start to look like
a completely new place.
Going to dark woods or
to an abandoned house,
you first think that, "Oh,
I don't want to go there
"because they are still so
nasty-looking dark places."
But to light painting, I
have examined these places
and they look beautiful.
You see the place differently.